now joining us now with more is the
attorney for former president donald
trump alina habba is with us along with
fox news legal analyst greg janet uh
jarrett is with us alina let me let me
go to this very important question of
how hillary was treated how sandy berger
was treated uh let's talk about that
february letter that they got from the
national archives and record
administration and let's talk about what
happened in june because it seems like
they were saying
in writing that donald trump was
cooperating
apparently he cooperated in june just
before this raid happened recently
so what changed in the interim
that's an incredibly good question so
first of all what's the difference
between
hillary and the predecessors well it's
very simple
donald trump is a republican he's
leading in the polls and that is a
problem for joe biden and anybody that's
going to be running against him if he
chooses to run in for 2024.
that's the answer to that question if he
was a registered democrat this wouldn't
have happened
for
um as far as miss wall's letter it
states very clearly that she was told by
counsel to president biden again like
you said misinformation they said they
didn't know but counsel to the president
said that he deferred to miss wall and
that she could then decide to just
remove the privilege that every
president prior has had um so
that's the issue there as to what
happened in between june and august well
we know what happened this was an event
that was prime right before election it
is prime because he's way ahead in the
polls and the wall street journal's
headlined today stated it perfectly
clearly this was an improper search it
was not done correctly there was no need
for it and he was cooperating there is
absolutely no reason no reason and now
we have evidence of that that they were
cooperating greg jarrett the night of
the raid at mar-a-lago you were on this
very program
and you pointed out what the wall street
journal mentioned today and that is that
the federal records act gives authority
to a former president to have custody
and control over presidential papers i
want you to talk about that and add to
that the right of a president to
declassify documents as he sees fit
which by the way is not something that
say a secretary of state like hillary
clinton could do
well and the other difference is that
there was overwhelming evidence of
intent on hillary clinton's part and the
statutes that she violated and should
have been prosecuted under
uh use terms like knowingly and
intentionally and deliberately well she
certainly did that
but here with president trump presidents
don't pack up their boxes
in the oval off they're not allowed to
it's by law
that's done by the gsa
uh does anybody think that when he got
down to mar-a-lago he sat in a room for
weeks on end or months on end going
through boxes and papers no of course
not and he cannot be held vicariously
culpable under the law
for the actions of his staff or auditors
or or lawyers
but the important part i point i made to
you the night of of the raid is that the
presidential records act is the
controlling statute it gives him a
measure of control and custody and
possession and access and of course
these two constitutional scholars in
today's wall street journal made the
exact same point merrick garland
knew all of that
there's no enforcement provision under
the records act it's not a crime so what
did merrick garland do he tossed in
three general criminal statutes well
wait a minute
under law for more than a hundred years
in america a specific statute like the
records act takes precedent and
supersedes any general statutes and
again garland
knew that but he wanted to gain access
to trump's compound for an ulterior
motive to look for some evidence any
evidence of a different crime maybe
something related to january 6.
so he tossed out a general warrant which
is a clear violation of the fourth
amendment which requires it to be
specific this wasn't and the magistrate
should never have signed it and i bet he
has a bit of buyer's remorse now which
is probably the reason why he wants to
divulge the contents of the affidavit
because maybe that shows not only lies
and misrepresentations
but omissions about how the president
had actually been cooperated and how a
subpoena should have been used instead
of a warrant
it's going to be very interesting to
watch unfold alina thank you greg
jarrett thank you hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else